GAINED 20 AND THE NASDAQ
FINISHED AHEAD 54.
BE BOLD BUT KNOW HOW TO PAY FOR
YOUR IDEAS WORDS FROM
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOCY
REPORTS ON HOW THE ADVICE WAS
RECEIVED.
>> THE DEMOCRAT TO WON ON A
PROMISE OF HOPE AND CHANGE JUST
TOLD DEMOCRATIC FRESHMAN HE
HOPES THEY CHANGE THEIR
APPROACH.
HE HUDDLED WITH HOUSE FRESHMAN
AND ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAID WE AS
DEMOCRATS SHOULDN'T BE AFRAID OF
BIG, BOLD IDEAS BUT ALSO NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW THOSE BIG, BOLD
IDEAS WILL WORK AND HOW YOU PAY
FOR THEM.
HIS ADVICE RESONATED WITH
FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN KATIE
HILL.
>> HE HAD A LOT OF ADVICE ABOUT
STICKING TO THE PLAN.
>> THE FEISTY PROGRESSIVE
PITCHES KEEP COMING LIKE PLANS
TO GIVE EVERY TEACHER IN AMERICA
A $13,500 RAISE FOR $315 BILLION
OVER TEN YEARS.
>> WE WILL PAY FOR IT BY
ADJUSTING THE ESTATE TAX.
RIGHT NOW IT'S ONLY $11 MILLION
AND WE NEED TO LOWER THAT.
>> ANOTHER PLAN MADE IT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR FOR A PROCEDURAL
VOTE, THE GREEN NEW DEAL WHICH
WILL COST TRILLIONS A DEER TO
IMPLEMENT.
MITCH McCONNELL SAYS HE WAS
GIVING PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
IN THE CHAMBER A CHANCE TO
SUPPORT A CAMPAIGN TRAIL STAPLE
BUT THE VOTE WAS NEVER EXPECTED
TO PASS.
>> NOW THEY WANT TO VOTE ON THE
GREEN NEW DEAL, WE WILL NOT FALL
FOR THIS STUNT.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND VOTED FOR
PRESENT.
>> IT SPONSORED, HE DIDN'T THINK
THE RESOLUTION WAS READY.
>> WE WON'T ALLOW THE
REPUBLICANS TO MAKE A MOCKERY OF
OUR DEMOCRATIC PROCESS BUT THERE
IS NOTHING HE COULD DO TO STOP
SENATOR MIKE LEE FROM TAKING THE
FLOOR WITH A HUGE PHOTO OF
AQUAMAN.
>> MAY I DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
THE 20-FOOT IMPRESSIVE SEA HORSE
HE'S WRITING.
UNDER THE GREAT NEW DEAL, THIS
IS PROBABLY HAWAII'S BEST BET.
>> WHEN CRITICS POINTED OUT THAT
ELIMINATING AIR TRAVEL OR EVEN
MEET COULD BE UNFEASIBLE,
DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
JUMPED TO DEFEND THE GREEN NEW
DEAL BUT TODAY, NONE OF THEM
VOTED TO ADVANCE IT SO THE
RESOLUTION EARNED ZERO VOTES IN